this video was voted for by patrons of
questions for science hydrogen peroxide
is the simplest peroxide molecule found
in nature it's composed of two oxygen
atoms bound to each other called a
peroxide group and one hydrogen atom
bound to both oxygen atoms so get it
hydrogen peroxide oh wow that makes
sense it has a bunch of applications
it's used in rocket propellant in
cosmetic products and most commonly as a
disinfectant but one thing hydrogen
peroxide is not is a health supplement
some people believe and quite strongly
to be frank that hydrogen peroxide is
this amazing panacea that's able to kill
off all kinds of viral infections like
herpes and HIV enhance your energy level
and increase the oxygen concentration in
your blood all the stems really from two
ideas the fact that hydrogen peroxide is
a disinfectant and that it contains two
oxygen atoms yeah these two reasons are
why people think hydrogen peroxide
therapy works but I mean come on if
you're gonna be drinking hydrogen
peroxide you might as well be drinking
hydrogen peroxide is an oxidizing agent
and oxidizing agents make great
disinfectants they work by bonding their
oxygen atoms to other molecules known in
a process as oxidation this oxidation
changes the molecule structure giving it
different properties which is how
peroxide kills bacteria okay so here's
the bacterial membrane it holds the
bacteria together and keeps the
cytoplasm and organelles safe when the
peroxide comes in contact with the
membrane it splits in half making a very
unstable molecule called a free radical
because it's unstable it needs to become
stable very quickly
it pulls the hydrogen atom from one of
the bacterial membrane lipids but now
the lipid contains a free radical which
again is very unstable so it takes a
hydrogen from a neighboring lipid
causing that lipid to form a free
radical as you can imagine this creates
a very destructive chain reaction now
just add a ton more hydrogen peroxide
and the entire membrane would become
dismantled causing cytoplasm and
organelles to break apart and leak from
the bacteria however this doesn't happen
in your body when you drink hydrogen
peroxide it sounds like people think it
works similar to antibiotics but it
doesn't when you take antibiotic
they dissolve in your stomach and get
absorbed into your blood through your
intestines from there the antibiotics
circulates throughout your body until it
reaches to colonize bacteria hydrogen
peroxide can't do this in the body when
you ingest it it's immediately broken
down upon contact with their cells this
is because our cells contain a special
enzyme called catalase which breaks down
the peroxide into water and oxygen this
explains why when you put peroxide on an
open cut it fizzles and bubbles up
because the cells are converting it into
water and oxygen our bodies carry the
catalase enzyme because we produce a
very small amount of our own hydrogen
peroxide in our cells stored in special
organelles called peroxisomes
peroxisomes recycle fatty acids in the
body and use the hydrogen peroxide to do
so via oxidation catalase is then
brought in to recycle the hydrogen
peroxide so it doesn't damage the cell
after the fatty acids are metabolized
and also the catalase enzyme has one of
the highest turnover rates of all
biological enzymes in the human body
it's capable of converting over a
million hydrogen peroxide molecules into
water and oxygen in one second
meaning it's insanely efficient so yeah
all that diluted peroxide that you're
drinking is totally deactivated within
seconds so really you're just drinking
water but hey it's important to stay
hydrated so you're doing something right
I guess secondly hydrogen peroxide
doesn't increase oxygen levels in your
blood yeah but but you're wrong because
it makes oxygen from it so the oxygen is
already in your body and because it's in
your body it's in your blood and that's
how it makes more oxygen for your blood
yeah okay well if you let me talk
something that you have to understand is
that the oxygen from the breakdown of
hydrogen peroxide and the oxygen that
you breathe in from the atmosphere are
not used by the body in the same way
when you inhale oxygen it gets absorbed
into your blood through your lungs this
oxygen then binds to red blood cells and
gets transported throughout your body
now oxygen from hydrogen peroxide is
used much differently when you drink
peroxide it goes down your esophagus and
into your stomach once there is
converted into water and oxygen either
by the catalase enzyme or by some
acids the oxygen made from this is in a
gaseous form and like all gases in your
stomach art so it's not used at all it's
completely useless there's no way for
the oxygen to get into your bloodstream
because gases don't get absorbed into
your blood for your stomach only through
your lungs sorry to ruin your day really
but these are the facts
breathing smoking and other air
pollutants as well as dehydration all
contribute to the deficiency of oxygen
in the body but there is a remedy for
this there is a cure there is a
substance that can be easily obtained
and use it is varied and expensive and
it can cure almost any disease and that
ladies and gentlemen is hydrogen
peroxide
[Music]
in order to understand how hydrogen
peroxide works you need to first
understand what hydrogen peroxide is
okie-doke
hydrogen peroxide h2o2 is nothing more
than water h2o with one extra oxygen
atom well and the fact that the second
hydrogen atom isn't bound to the same
oxygen and the properties are vastly
different but it's a decent description
moving on there are several grades and
concentrations of hydrogen peroxide
there is a pharmaceutical grade which is
the grade you will find in the drugstore
this comes in a little brown bottle at a
concentration of 3% hydrogen peroxide
the rest of it is purified water and
added stabilizers these stabilizers
include chemicals such as phenol sodium
Stan 8 and tetra sodium phosphate and
even though this grade a percentage of
h2o 2 may seem great for cuts burns and
mouthwash it's garbage well you know the
manufacturers put those stabilizers in
there because they didn't think people
would actually be drinking hydrogen
peroxide much like how we never thought
people would be eating bleach spots in
2018 but hey you got to thin out the
herd somehow also food grade 35%
peroxide doesn't have stabilizers
because it's in a higher concentration
and will last longer than a 3%
concentration you can sanitize just
about anything with this stuff uh yeah
exactly it's meant to be used as a
sanitizer you can use it internally to
cleanse and heal yourself of almost any
disease no this is grossly incorrect
hydrogen peroxide doesn't kill bacteria
or viruses inside your body the only way
can kill a bacteria is by being directly
exposed to it like on a cut or on food
as said before hydrogen peroxide is
broken down in the body almost
immediately into water and oxygen the
preserved molecule never makes it into
your bloodstream besides the best way to
fight infection or disease is with the
healthy immune system I have done this
protocol and there are several
variations of it but this is basically
how it's done
you take your 35 percent food grade
hydrogen peroxide an eyedropper and
eight to ten ounces of distilled
water you take your eyedropper and you
place one drop in your glass of
distilled water hey man I don't know if
you took a second to do the math with
this dilution stuff but it's cool fan I
got you
so one drop of thirty five percent
hydrogen peroxide into nine ounces of
distilled water dramatically dilutes the
peroxide from 35% down to zero point
zero zero seven percent which is four
hundred twenty eight times weaker than
the three percent solution you buy at
the drugstore it's garbage and even at
the high end of twenty five drops per
nine ounces of water it's only at 0.16
percent still eighteen times weaker than
the three percent solution this is
already an incredibly weak concentration
of hydrogen peroxide and then when you
factor in that it's enzymatic be broken
down once in the body it's safe to say
that virtually zero percent of the
hydrogen peroxide is left over to have
any kind of effect whether it be good
bad or neutral on the body you take your
eyedropper and you place one drop in
your glass of distilled water some
people say you can start with three
drops trust me start with one before you
drink this you must make sure that there
is nothing in your stomach hey I'm just
saying this and you can take or leave it
but this protocol sounds more like a
bunch of witches brewing a spell than a
medical treatment that means you're
going to have to time yourself when you
take this stuff because you're going to
need to do this at least twice a day
each day you increase the dosage by one
drop per day so the first day it was one
drop three times a day you increased it
to two drops three times a day three
drops three times a day
crease it by two drops per day up until
you get around twenty-five drops three
times a day close to two weeks after
that you begin to do the protocol in
Reverse I mean when I get antibiotics my
doctor says just take one pill a day for
a month it's pretty cut and dry so what
you are doing is you are pumping up the
oxygen levels in your blood and
maintaining those levels so your body
has the time to use that extra oxygen to
repair and heal you true you can
increase blood oxygen by exercising
drinking more water and maintaining a
specific diet however drinking hydrogen
peroxide as explained before does not
increase blood oxygen at all and even if
it could there's a limit as
how much oxygen can be in your blood
it's not like you can have 50% more
oxygen in your blood than the average
person too much or too little oxygen in
your blood is bad your blood pH must
stay at 7.4 just a little high or a
little low can be fatal too much oxygen
raises the pH above 7.4 causing
alkalosis your energy level goes up you
sleep better your body burns fat faster
and you lose weight your eyesight
improves your brain is highly oxygenated
so you can think more clearly hmm okay
do you have sources or mechanism
explaining how I provided mine sayers
who will suggest that this doesn't work
and or you end up damaging your body in
the end and I can tell you they don't
know what the hell they're talking about
never take advice from someone who
clearly has not done the damn protocol
if I've never used penicillin that
doesn't mean I can tell someone hey I've
never objectively used this as an
antibiotic and because of that I can say
that it doesn't work no I don't have to
use it to confirm it works instead I can
cite literally 91 years of studies and
experiments that prove it does work this
is something that hydrogen peroxide
therapy lacks a lot of sufficient
reproducible studies ozone therapy works
it has been proven to work countless
times countless times eh okay great do
you have a list of scientific papers or
references that prove this any journals
no there's no double-blind studies or
large number of study participants
nothing not even just like a one person
besides yourself okay well then this is
both now if you want to disregard
everything I've said in this video then
the more power to you but just know this
one simple thing hydrogen peroxide is an
oxidant it causes oxidation to molecules
which is why it's so effective at
killing bacteria fun fact
oxidation also causes cancer which is
why antioxidants are important to have
in your diet to prevent cancer this is
why you need to eat fruits and
vegetables because they contain vitamins
and surprise vitamins are antioxidants
on the stupid scale hydrogen peroxide
therapy is at a six out of ten and on
the harmful scale it's at eight
out of ten as the average untrained
person making and drinking their own
delusions of caustic 35% hydrogen
peroxide just sounds like a trip to the
ER and just a quick shout-out to my
patrons for voting for this video and
supporting my future projects thank you
for watching and stay tuned
[Music]